fantastic beast is your first big
franchise
what things do you have to consider when
deciding whether or not to sign on for
that film
that you've never had to consider when
choosing whether or not to take a role
before just really didn't know what i
was getting into to be honest it was
just
i didn't realize what a different thing
a franchise is from a film you know
the the commitment the duration of the
shoot
the um duration
of the press tours you know really how
much
of your year it asks of you
um and um
[Music]
yeah and i think the things that sort of
got get me through it and really ground
me in it
are that on set when you're trying to
tell the story it feels the same thank
god
because if that wasn't the case i think
i will feel completely
um out of place
in in that kind of environment because
because it is a very big machine um but
ultimately the job's thankfully still
the same which is like
can you connect with this person in this
quiet moment
i feel like with franchises it's a
little rare to see
one director helm all of these
and i i don't necessarily know if this
is still the plan but do you think it
would be more beneficial for that
franchise
for david to be directing all of the
installments
i think he is meant to direct them all i
think it's very interesting you know he
he's worked very closely with jk rowling
for a long time and
very few people have access to her so
she because she's quite
insulated um and so
i can't really imagine how it could work
any other way frankly
and before i leave this one i have to
ask how is it working with mads
mikkelsen because he's just the best and
should be cast in
everything you know i hung out with mads
in venice we were there at the same time
um this summer and i've never met him
before and
i had a great time with him he's totally
lovely um but that was before he was
cast
and i think that's right yeah i think it
was just before he was cast and we don't
have anything together in the film so
i don't know what it's like to work with
him unfortunately but maybe someday we
will
i'm sad for you but i'm happy that as
you go